[Music]
when people think about appalachia they
probably think about forests and
mountains and maybe they also think
about coal mines
but when you go there you see that
there's actually also
gas wells all over the place the whole
region is covered in gas wells
in many cases these marginal wells
they're actually a lot dirtier than coal
because so much of the methane that
comes out of these wells is actually
escaping into the air rather than going
into a pipeline
and so we kind of got interested in
asking the question well who who owns
these wells
we realize this company diversified
energy owns far more wells than anyone
else in appalachia
diversified says it owns over 60 000
wells that makes it the biggest well
owner in america beating out exxon
beating out chevron
the fact that this one company was
buying up so many of these wells across
appalachia kind of piqued our curiosity
and so we decided to go out into the
mountains and see for ourselves what was
going on at all these wells
so as an energy reporter when we think
of methane emissions a lot of times we
think about what's going on in the
permian basin in west texas which is
where we have a lot of this new
production where you see a lot of the
new methane emissions
methane is a greenhouse gas and it's
also the main component of natural gas
and it's a particular problem because if
you have the same amount of methane and
the same amount of carbon dioxide when
both rise up into the atmosphere methane
has a far greater warming potential
and scientists think that about a
quarter of all the human-caused warming
that we've experienced to date is
because of methane emissions by humans
if you think of the us as having
somewhere around one million active oil
and gas wells today
about three-quarters of them are
marginal or stripper wells these tiny
producers
in many cases they're just kind of like
these old rusted pieces of equipment
and what the research shows is that
these types of wells
are actually a pretty big contributor
to the methane problem because they're
far more likely to have leaks they're
not super well maintained
most of the big companies you've heard
of in in the oil business exxon and
chevron they don't want to be owning a
bunch of old wells in the middle of
nowhere that were drilled in the 1960s
but it turns out that there's this one
company that has the exact opposite
approach they've bought up
essentially all the old wells they can
get
diversified energy they just became a
huge huge player
and it's a company that not only most
americans haven't heard of but even
people who are in the oil and gas
industry in houston have not heard of
before
we'd read all this research that shows
these marginal wells can actually be
major contributors to climate change and
so
we were curious about whether
diversified energy's wells were among
those that might have leaks in them
so we decided to go to appalachia and
see for ourselves
[Music]
we didn't have permission from the
company to visit any of their sites on
private land and so we focused on sites
that were on public land so state game
lands national forests places like that
it required a lot of hiking
a lot of the places the weeds were you
know up to our waist or higher we were
just kind of hoping you were going in
the right direction
definitely should have brought a machete
we are not
professional methane hunters and so
rachel actually
took a course and got certified as an
optical gas imaging thermographer
methane emissions are invisible to the
human eye it's not something that you
can go out and see
and
there are these cameras that allow the
operator to see methane you can go into
the high sensitivity mode
and you can really see it
and then we also got a sniffer device
that can actually test the air and
identify methane
so the first day
we started in pennsylvania and we drove
as close as we could to the latin long
of the first well
we hiked probably about 20 minutes until
we came to the well
[Music]
you can see here that
there is a leak that we're looking at
so the very first wall that we went to
was leaking
[Music]
and then we went to our second well
which was on the same patch of game land
uh that one was also emitting methane
right about here
i think we went to six or seven walls
before we found the one that didn't have
emissions significant enough to set off
the gas detector
in a few of the case where we found
emissions those emissions may have been
part of the normal operating of the well
rather than a leak but in the vast
majority of cases we found it was
unintentional leaking
[Music]
day two was ohio
it was pretty wild it was kind of like
one of those movies where the
adventurers are going through a jungle
and suddenly they they uncover some kind
of like evidence of a lost civilization
there was just vines and growth covering
everything
in ohio we
also saw wells that were leaking
probably the same rate as the ones that
were leaking in pennsylvania
you can see at this joint just moisture
from the dew this morning
is bubbling for some reason
[Music]
that alarm means that uh we've reached a
point of 10 percent of uh
the amount of methane it would take to
be able to ignite so clearly there's a
there's a leak here
and then the third day we went to west
virginia
west virginia is very difficult
topography we'd get out there and we
would walk for like two hours trying to
figure out where the trail is and losing
it and then finding it again
that
[Music]
back
i'm i'm up here
up this way guys it's really back here
[Music]
so the air right down there is
almost enough to light on fire
i was pretty surprised um i guess i was
anticipating that maybe fewer were
emitting then weren't
and what we found was that that wasn't
the case
in all about 60 of the 44 wells we
visited did have methane emissions
significant enough to set off the gas
detector
so after our trip we told diversified
what we'd found
they said that you couldn't draw many
conclusions from visits to just 44 wells
considering all the thousands and
thousands of wells that they own
and they also said that in some cases
the problems we were seeing were because
of previous owners that hadn't been
neglecting the wells and that they had
acquired these wells only recently
diversified said it actually sent people
out to all the wells that we told them
about and they were able to find all the
leaks and fix them
relatively quickly and cheaply for about
90 bucks on average and diversified says
a lot of the leaks they found were
pretty small
and it's true you can't tell from the
camera or the gas detector how much
methane is leaking out you can just tell
that some is
so while we were in appalachia we tried
to figure out how much methane was
leaking out of a few wells
we were able to go out in the field with
amy townsend small who's a professor at
university of cincinnati and she has a
device that can actually quantify
methane emissions
the first step is to find if there are
leaks at
a marginal well and then if there's a
certain level of methane we can measure
the emission rate with a high flow
sampler
in my head i've thought of this like
big fancy machine it's kind of it's this
weird like kind of metal contraption
with these like tubes coming out of it
like one of the main parts is just like
the same kind of
hose that you have on your vacuum
cleaner now what does it say a three 3.4
okay
we take her to three of the walls we had
been to the previous day
there's another big leak right there
you're right wow
good job you guys
it was interesting after three days of
seeing these leaks to have some sort of
context as to how big they were
one of the wells we went to it was
barely producing any gas at all
last year it produced 8 000 cubic feet
for the entire year which is nothing the
leak rate that she calculated there was
actually 600
of that 8 000 cubic feet
the wells that we measured today are
representative of most of the wells in
america
they're not just a problem for
greenhouse gas emissions they're a
potential health hazard and
explosion hazard
if they're leaking more than they're
producing especially they need to be
plugged
[Music]
when the well is no longer productive
you need to plug it you need to pour
some cement down there to inactivate it
and that can cost anywhere from 10 to 25
000 to you know upwards of a hundred
thousand dollars
so owning a bunch of old wells it looks
like this huge amount of liabilities
but we realized doing research that what
this company diversified did is kind of
turn that on its head
diversified energy they promote this
idea of what they call smarter asset
management basically they say that they
can run these wells
longer cheaper and better than other
companies
their whole business strategy is
essentially to say we're going to be
able to just kind of keep pumping
gas out of these wells for a long time
before we ever have to think about
plugging them
and the climate angle to that is that
the longer you wait before plugging
wells that really ought to be plugged
the more methane is going to be escaping
into the air
now regulators have been pretty alarmed
uh to see this happening
so in 2018 the pennsylvania department
of environmental protection ordered a
subsidiary of diversified called
alliance petroleum to plug several
hundred wells
a few weeks later diversified appeals
that order and says that they disagree
with some of the conclusions that the
state had reached surrounding weld
plugging
they ended up kind of cutting this deal
with diversified that actually doesn't
require them to plug hardly any wells at
all they only have to plug 20 a year in
pennsylvania for instance even though
they own 20 000 wells so do the math
it'll take them a thousand years to plug
all these wells
but the regulators are in a very tough
position
it's almost like they made it too big to
fail oil company
a failure of diversified would be a
disaster for the state budgets of
pennsylvania ohio and west virginia
because all of a sudden they would
inherit this this huge amount of
liabilities all these old wells that
they that they don't have the money to
plug
[Music]
now it's it's important to say that
diversified has been very clear that
they don't think this is a problem
they'll generate enough profit from oil
and gas to eventually plug all these
wells and there's nothing to worry about
at the end of the day what we're really
focused on is our commitment to our
shareholders
making sure that we're growing the
company in a very
safe
way
what diversified has told its investors
is that the company is trying to
replicate what it's done in appalachia
in louisiana perhaps in texas
i think it'll be interesting to see
whether the states down here do anything
differently than the states uh
in appalachia where diversified was able
to extend these plugging agreements
to the extent that lawmakers are
thinking about this stuff at all they're
thinking about what are we doing to
properly regulate frack wells that are
producing
vast amounts of gas
what they're not so much thinking about
is
you know there's this other problem with
all these wells that have been around a
long time
there was one well that we visited in
pennsylvania that kind of sums up the
whole
situation in a way
we had kind of made it through like the
trees into this little clearing but we
couldn't see anything and we were
getting ready to call it and we see like
just like the bones of this really old
uh well it was yellow but pretty rusty
this is a well that as far as we know
last produced any gas for sale back in
1998
it's not even hooked up to a pipeline
anymore it's just basically a pipe
sticking out of the ground
i turned on the camera and booted it up
and you could see that there was nothing
coming out of that open pipe and it was
strange because there were like these
two hot spots
inside
after a while we could see that there
were two bees inside the pipe
[Music]
this is a well that even diversified
doesn't think that they can get it to
produce so it's on the list to be
plugged but in pennsylvania diversified
only has to plug 20 wells per year and
so this well like thousands of others
are just kind of waiting around
for their turn to come
and this well's turn hasn't come yet
[Music]
you